he was once considered untouchable but
former Malaysian Prime Minister Najib
Razak now faces the second of four
trials this time to answer 25 criminal
charges of money laundering and abuse of
power in relation to more than half a
billion dollars that prosecutors say
were stolen from 1mdb the state
investment fund he set up in 2009
Najib is already on trial involving the
transfer of ten million dollars from SRC
International a former subsidiary of
1mdb
into his personal accounts he has denied
any wrongdoing saying the money was a
donation from Saudi Arabia most of which
his since returned allegations of
Najib's involvement in losses at 1mdb
surfaced when he was prime minister but
he was cleared by the police at the time
and the then Attorney General the case
was reopened when a new government led
by Mahathir Mohamad came into power in
May 2018 it represents a fulfillment of
for example the government of Malaysia's
electro promised to the voters of
Malaysia that they're gonna go to the
bottom of this 1mdb series of
irregularities and skandos not chips
home and other properties linked to him
and his family were raided last year
police said they seized cash jewelry
handbags and watches worth up to two
hundred and seventeen million dollars
1mdb is also being investigated in other
jurisdictions including the US it isn't
just those with direct links to 1mdb
who've been charged
prosecutors in Malaysia and the US have
filed criminal charges against two
of goldman sachs malaysia is also going
after the investment bank itself which
had helped her issue six billion dollars
in bonds meant to finance development in
the country prosecutors alleged money
intended for 1mdb was instead used on
extravagant purchases including a luxury
yacht by one of Nod jibs associates last
month malaysian prosecutors charged
Najib's stepson RZA Oz's a co-founder of
a Hollywood production firm with
money-laundering alleging he
misappropriated 248 million dollars
linked to one and dB the Malaysian
government meanwhile is also seeking to
recover five billion dollars worth of
assets that it believes were bought with
money stolen from 1mdb Florence Dewey al
Jazeera Kuala Lumpur